COLT MCANLIS: In this episode
of "Cloud Performance Atlas,"
I help some streaming chefs
avoid performance heartburn.
Will we master the
secret ingredient?
Stay tuned to find out.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Previously we covered
the various ways
to profile and get
visibility into the startup
time for Kubernetes pod, which
is important since that's
exactly where the Bacon, Live!
Team was running into a problem.
Their startup performance was
behaving like a piece of dried
out kale--
because it's a food app--
it's a pun.
Anyhow, let's gets to profiling.
Bacon, Live! had
ported their code
from Compute Engine to
Container Engine, and as such,
all of their
containers initialized
in the parallel phase
of the pod boot process.
In fairness, they did have
a single Init Container that
was doing some,
"sorry, bald guy,
we can't tell you
about that work,"
but we'll ignore that for now.
Applying the profiling
process from before,
we ended up getting
the following data.
Three of the containers were
taking a significant amount
of time to boot up.
Most impacted were the
public and admin endpoints,
which was problematic
since those
were crucial for the
usage of their system.
Looking at that code
for the public endpoint,
the reason for this problem
became crystal clear.
The initialization code
for the public container
was doing a quick call
over to the stats container
to make sure it
was up and running
before proceeding forward.
The problem is
that the URL fetch
command is a blocking call.
The result is that the
public endpoints Init
code was waiting around
for the stats container
to finish initializing
before moving forward.
Obviously, this was not ideal.
Since it looked like
we had a dependency
on the stats container,
our first attempt
to solve this involved moving
that container into the Init
phase so that the parallel
containers didn't have to get
caught in this
weird race condition
and could execute properly.
But when we timed things
again, we realized our mistake.
The Init phase got two
to four seconds longer,
which resulted in the
entire system startup
being worse off in
general since all
of the rest of the containers
were delayed as well.
This was obviously
the wrong direction
and made the whole
boot time slower.
At this point, the Bacon, Live!
Team decided to go back through
and make some small changes
to their code.
The Stats module was there
to help do timings of startup
related tasks, but since they
now had visibility into those
things outside of their code--
thanks to the profiling harness
we'd set up for them--
they were happy to
remove the dependencies
for these endpoints.
This allowed them to get the
same timing information as
before and move
the stats container
back to the parallel phase
without the dependencies.
The result was about
two seconds improvement
in availability time for
their public endpoints.
The Bacon, Live!
Team realized a critical
pattern for startup performance
in Kubernetes-- avoid
parallel Init dependencies
where possible.
Thankfully, we were
able to profile it, get
visibility of the problem, and
fix it before anybody noticed.
If you'd like to learn more
tips and tricks for making
your cloud as fast
as possible, make
sure to check out the rest of
the "Cloud Performance Atlas"
content because when it
comes to performance,
every millisecond counts.
[MUSIC PLAYING]